[Musique]
ce mercredi 31 mai au domaine Moka se
sont tenus les assises contre les
violences intrafamiliales une rencontre
organisée par la préfecture afin de
réunir et d'échanger avec les acteurs de
la lutte contre ces violences
le pourquoi de ces violences a été
l'objet des travaux de ce matin et cet
après-midi il y aura entre expert entre
professionnels 4 ateliers qui vont
permettre d'approfondir certains sujets
sur la santé des femmes sur la prise en
charge des mineurs qui sont souvent les
oubliées dans ces violences
intrafamiliales et ces assises nous
espérons qu'elles vont donner un souffle
supplémentaire à l'action collective qui
est nécessaire pour lutter contre les
violences c'est vraiment une conviction
chez nous je m'étais engagée à le faire
en 2023 il y aura une déclinaison qui
continuera de bien d'autres formes et
tout ça on ne peut y arriver que parce
qu'il y a un travail très partenariat
état justice collectivité territoriales
a commencé bien sûr par le département
qui avec son rôle de chef de fil de
l'action sociale du chef de fil de la
petite enfance et déjà très engagé et le
président du Département je le sais et
désireux de faire encore plus donc ce
partenariat avec le tissu associatif
avec les familles avec les individus les
personnes
réunionnaises réunionnais qui elle-même
ont un rôle à jouer tout ça doit nous
permettre de faire beaucoup plus et
quand on se réunira à nouveau de
constater qu'on a encore parcouru un
chemin important le département de La
Réunion fait de cette lutte une des
priorités de sa mandature
on met en place en fait des dispositifs
d'accompagnement pour les personnes
vulnérables et victimes de violence que
ce soit les enfants que ce soit les
parents victimes de violence donc à
travers des lieux d'accueil des lieux
d'écoute comme la PMI avec les
intervenants au commissariat et en
gendarmerie donc on a augmenté les
moyens on a augmenté les effectifs pour
pouvoir accompagner les personnes le
département s'organise en interne pour
accompagner les publics les plus
vulnérables les enfants les parents donc
on a des dispositifs qui sont mis en
place par exemple pour l'accompagnement
à la parentalité avec le dispositif
Panzo
l'accompagnement dans l'éducation avec
le dispositif d'ACD et on accompagne
aussi tous les partenaires les
associations évidemment à travers les
subventions qu'on apporte aux
associations pour travailler ensemble je
suis très heureuse et très satisfaite de
la tenue de la Table Ronde de ce matin
de la qualité des échanges parce que il
est vrai que la question c'est de
traiter en effet les urgences mais on
avait évoqué cela avec la venue du
ministre qu'il était très important de
travailler en parallèle sur les racines
de la violence cela me paraît essentiel
en fait de comprendre le mécanisme de
violence parce que cela va nous
permettre de stopper l'escalade de
violence
parmi les solutions concrètes proposées
ce mercredi le dispositif mon chéri un
bouton d'alerte connecté au creux d'un
bijou c'est un bouton d'alerte
dispositif
discret qui permet d'alerter lorsque
nous sommes en danger qui permettent de
sécuriser et qui permet de mettre en
relation d'envoyer en un simple clic un
clic un sms cinq personnes de prévenu
deux clics
un double appel donc ce qui permet aux
personnes qu'on a présélectionné dans
notre
application d'être prévenu en simultané
aussi de notre position géolocalisée
donc vous appuyez sur un petit lien
sur le petit SMS que vous avez reçu ça
permet de vous mettre en relation et ça
permet de savoir exactement où est la
victime l'engagement du département dans
ce combat se poursuivra notamment le 22
juin au travers de l'odpe l'observatoire
départemental de la protection de
l'enfance
[Musique]